we're joined Now by a retired Air Vice
Marshall Sean bellshaw great to see you
as always well
um so so firstly of course we should say
getting a statement of criticism from
from the Taliban might not be something
that that angers a former uh or upsets a
former Soldier I mean with that partly
in mind is there guidance that you get
when in the Army when coming back from a
tour when leaving the army or the Armed
Forces uh more broadly I should say in
terms of what you do and don't say on
this sort of topic well there's two
things one of the official Secrets acts
which everybody signs up to and that's
legally binding this is not part of the
official secret sack this is more about
guidance but it at wartime experiences
are really interesting because I do a
lot of work with the Second World War
veterans not many of them left now very
few of them ever talked about their time
on the battlefields in the air during
the war because it was so horrendous
that actually they didn't want they
couldn't find a place in peaceful
Society to share those experiences and
yet many of them were absolutely Heroes
and I think the challenge here is that
we don't normally hear about what's been
happening on the battlefields except we
now hear about this in a book and that's
what's been a bit unfortunate here and
just talk us through this point he
mentions there you know in the age of
Apaches and laptops the the specifics of
his record are are recorded I mean talk
us through give us some color on that
yeah I think it's it's definitely worth
having some context here so um Harry
served in Afghanistan and our tour is
overlapped I did two years of my life
three tours out out there
um he said with a great deal of
Distinction out there he was in a very
very difficult role on the front line
flying Apaches providing close air
support to us our friendly soldiers on
the ground and because it's a high-tech
uh platform you do a detailed planning
before you go but more importantly
everything is recorded in the cockpit
and you do very detailed debriefs
afterwards part of that is did I hit my
target you know is there any way I could
do it better do I count the number of
casualties but more importantly did I
put at risk any of our Personnel on the
ground and it's all to do with how do
you do it better the next time around so
it's really Fierce professionalism and
ruthless the challenge here of course is
soldiers it's at the Second World War
veterans they see their their colleagues
being blown up on the battlefields that
lives with them Pilots are detached from
all that but they have to live with the
consequences of what they see on the
screen when they do their debriefs and
part of that leads to PTSD I think one
thing I'll criticize of what Harry's
done is just this number 25 we live it's
a grave risk that it gets
misrepresented we live in a world where
lots of the younger generation play
computer games war games and body bags
are a sort of badge of honor in some way
I can reassure that none of the military
take any Pride whatsoever in killing
individuals it is a ruthless game that
everybody knows they are human beings
father sons and and husbands and
increasingly females as well and I think
whatever Harry has done in his
post-military career it's not for me to
judge but he did serve this country with
pride and courage in during his time in
Afghanistan sure well as always thanks
so much